In this lesson, let's go and take a look at some key points when it comes to Lumen, as
well as some optimizing and editing that we can do.
So let's get started.
One of the things you want to make sure you do when working with Lumen is you want to
make sure that you're turning off any static lighting that may be on by default.
So we have allow static lighting, and we also have ambient occlusion static fraction bake
lighting.
We want to turn these off because we're not using baking.
This is for better AO built into Lumen, and we're not leaning on any other kind of defaults
in here for lighting.
And to make sure you're not using the old default.
So again, turning those off, and you'll find these in your project settings, you want to
turn off your ambient occlusion static fraction, and you want to turn off your allow static
lighting.
Turn those off.
So the bottom graphic here is what you want to shoot for.
You also can adjust and fix any mesh distance field issues that you may be coming into where
it doesn't quite look as clean as you want.
So in under rendering in our project settings, we can go to our distance field voxel density
and increase that as we need to.
But keep in mind as you increase that, it does get a bit expensive GPU wise.
So just note to self, also in each individual object, you can actually go into the distance
field resolution scale and increase it if you feel that that shadow needs better representation.
Typically out of the box, it does a really good job, but we haven't implemented these
in here so that if you need to adjust them, you can and you can go to these two areas.
One, the project settings into inside of the object itself.
So again, like I say all the time, it's good to practice to pair Lumen with that night
for a high visual fidelity, as well as virtual shadow maps.
So you want to make sure you're working with all of these and you're going to get a bit
more realistic of a scene and be able to put more into the scene as you build it out.
So hardware ray tracing.
So it supports a larger range of geometry like we mentioned before, more types than
software ray tracing.
In particular, it supports tracing against skin dimensions, which is really important.
Software ray tracing also scales up better to higher qualities and it intersects against
the actual triangles and has the option to evaluate lighting at the ray hit instead of
the lower quality surface catch.
And this is something that we mentioned before.
So make sure you keep that in mind.
This is really important because you can actually get a better quality overall visual representation
for your scene and you'll see software ray tracing mode here.
There's a detail tracing and there's a hit lighting reflection.
So you can actually bump these up to get better visuals overall.
And again, you can find this under engine rendering, which we talked about in the beginning
of the course.
So optimizing and editing in Unreal.
So what happens when it comes to Lumen is a Lumen captures the material properties for
each mesh from multiple angles.
It's called cards and it digest this information so that it lets Lumen know exactly how that
geometry is built and how to get it at the best possible representation in your real
time 3D scenario.
Now you can increase these cards or I should say you should be able to not only increase
the cards, but you can actually see them.
So this first output log, I should say CVAR in here, they can put into your output log
or your console variables.
You can actually see the cards in place.
And let me show you what I mean.
Let's go ahead and go to Unreal and implement this.
So I'm going to go ahead and just go simply to the output log.
I'm going to go and place this in here and hit enter.
And we can now see the cards here that are being digested.
And it's actually calculating and using these little volumetric boxes here to give us the
needed visuals in our scene.
It's actually taking that information from each piece of geometry.
And you can see it in here masked out and captured within each cube that these cards
are evaluating and looking at our overall scene.
Now if you ever forget what these do and you're like card placement, show me where the cards
are to help Lumen do its work, you can also put a question mark and then Unreal will give
you a brief breakdown of what it does.
Now in this particular case it has failed.
It doesn't do it all the time.
But this allows you to actually see, you can put a question mark around most of all the
CVARs and it'll tell you what it does.
So the surface cache here can be used to see areas that don't have surface cache on coverage.
They are colored pink in the surface cache and view mode of the level editor.
And you can see this if we switch to that in Unreal, you can see some of this going on
with the cliffs.
Now one thing I want to point out here, there's a lot of errors on this particular piece of
geometry.
And the reason why is because this piece of geometry is not built in a modular fashion,
which it should be.
So when you build things for Lumen, you want to make sure that you're building an actual
wall, a wall in pieces, the floor, the ceiling, and you want to build it logically like something's
actually built, like LEGO.
You can think of it that way.
And that gives you the best possible calculation with less light leaking or any obscure shadow
areas going on.
So that's how you want to approach that.
And that's why you're seeing a lot of errors on this particular piece of geometry.
Let's go to Unreal and turn this on briefly and you can see what I'm talking about.
So in here, we'll go to our lit mode and we're going to go to Lumen and you can see surface
cache.
So again, it tells you visualizes Lumen surface cache and pink is missing surface cache coverage
yellow called meshes.
So if we click on this, you'll see there are a few areas where we're getting some errors,
but they're not major.
We don't have to worry about them too much.
There's just some areas where it's not quite getting as digested and being processed exactly
the way that we want.
But overall, it's not too bad.
And we can go ahead and turn that off.
The reason why this is doing a bit better, obviously, dramatically better compared to
that room that I showed you example of is because we've built this in separate pieces.
But there are thin pieces of geometry in here due to the fact that these are been have been
scanned, the nature of scanning, these guys are hollow.
If I really needed to, I could take them into a DCC, thicken them out and do a little UV
and then I could do the same thing even in Unreal using the modeling tools because you'll
see that they are quite thin.
And you can see in the backside a lot of light leaking that is occurring because they are
thin having solid geometry is always the best if you possibly can get that implemented.
So this occurs a lot of the times when you have a complicated piece of geometry and you
can actually help yourself out if you break those pieces up a bit and again, build it
like Legos.
But you can also increase the Lumen card in here.
You can make it so you have more cards per task in here.
So you can see max Lumen mesh cards.
We can increase that max Lumen mesh cards to a higher number of value.
Now, again, this is up to you and how you edit your piece of geometry and how it was built,
how it was scanned.
There's multiple factors in here to be able to get your scene to look a bit better if
for some reason you're noticing that things aren't quite looking as cleanly as you'd
want them to because these areas will not bounce light and will appear black in your
reflections and you kind of want to avoid that.
Now, again, I repeat this quite often.
Use Nenite as much as possible with Lumen for best results.
If you decide to mix it up and use Nenites and you're using LUDs, you can get a performance
effect because they're not really made for that.
I mean, you can use Nenite for a regular baking scenario, but if you do on the flip side,
use LUD and Nenite, you've got to be careful with that.
We've had some gaming clients run into issues with that, especially for larger environments.
So for the best performance, again, Lumen, virtual shadow maps and Nenite are going to
be your best approach.
So in other words, Nenite accelerates the mesh captures used to keep the surface catch
in sync with the triangle scene.
So after the surface catch is populated with material properties, Lumen calculates direct
and indirect lighting for these surface positions.
So you can see how they really like each other.
So projects with extreme overlapping instances can control the method Lumen uses with the
project settings, software ray tracing mode.
And Lumen provides two options to choose from.
So we have detailed tracing and we have global tracing.
So one is detailed tracing gives you higher visual fidelity.
And then the global tracing is a bit more dumbed down and gives you some faster traces
in here.
It's the for the fastest traces you can possibly get with your global distance field.
So you can think of it as performance versus your visuals.
You again, this is a case by case, whatever you might need.
So that things look the best in the scenario that you've built.
If you're noticing in your shadows as you're moving around in your environment, maybe from
a larger distance and maybe more geared towards virtual production, less maybe advice to be
effects, it just depends on where your camera is at.
But if you're noticing your shadows seem to disappear, fade in and out, what you can do
in each light, you can disable your ray tracing cast shadows.
So let me show you where that's at in your light.
If you forgot.
So in Unreal, if I click on my directional light, I can actually go down here to my advanced
area here.
And you'll see that we have a few things in the ray tracing department that has been set
up.
It's down here.
I'm clicking the wrong area.
So you'll see my cast ray traced shadows is disabled.
So you can turn that off.
If you're, if it seems like you're getting a shadow conflict where your shadows are popping
in and out based on your camera coming closer or farther away from an object.
So that's something you can do if you do run into that issue.
Now we also go over this particular tool on another class.
If you needed to, you can also use a level snapshot so you can update what your visuals
are in your scene on the fly.
And the director and your production team is going to love it because then you can,
you don't have to commit.
You can actually change it.
And I have a few of those in my scene and let me show you real quick briefly.
Again, we do have a class that talks about this in detail, but I'm just going to show
you kind of how cool it is.
So I'm going to go in here and open up my level snapshot.
Now opening up my level snapshot, it shows me some really older ones we have here.
I'm not going to worry about them right now.
So what I'm going to do is go ahead and make a new one.
So we're going to go and take a level snapshot of what we have.
We'll give it a description.
I'll just call this awesome.
Just awesome.
Nothing else.
And we'll hit create.
Now I'm not going to get into all the details for the interface.
And then what we can do is make another one just simply by moving our camera around or
I should say light.
Excuse me.
I say camera.
I did.
I did say camera.
Make that a bit brighter.
And we'll take a snapshot of that, maybe even changing it so it's a little more dramatic.
Barely peeking the light in the side snapshot.
Another awesome.
And we'll say create level snapshot.
So you can flip through these once you've made them and you can actually play with them
a bit and do whatever you want, which is actually kind of cool.
So I can say, hey, I want to show off what this one looks like.
You can double click on it.
Restore level snapshot.
It will show me.
And then you can always go back to the one that you had before.
Double click on it.
Restore level snapshot.
And it'll restore it.
It'll actually shuffle even the geometry if you change your geometry.
Now you'll notice my geometry degraded here because I had changed a few things.
So it went back to where that texture material was before.
So it tries to keep all that stuff in memory.
That's it with this lesson.
Here's a few links that will help you get you in the right direction talking about those
details in Lumen.
And the next lesson, we're going to take a look at light mass and baking the old school
way in Unreal using CPU and GPU light mass.
Thanks again.